welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and after weeks of
waiting for an official statement from
Sony or Disney we finally have word from
the CEO of Sony Pictures Tony Vince
Akira that things are over throughout
this video I'm just gonna be breaking
down the entire statement of what he
said and what this means for the future
of the character now there were rumors
that both companies were in talks with
one another this week and this was
backed up by Jon Favreau who at the
entertainment and technology summit said
that the split was not due to lack of
trying on Disney's part as of now which
is Friday the 6th of September we've had
official word that quote for the moment
the door is closed
Vince Akira spoke to Variety at the
entertainment and technology summit
staying that there was no ill-will
between the companies but the ads of now
the two have failed to reach an
agreement on how to finance and split
the revenue of the characters Vince
Akira said that it's been an interesting
couple of weeks when asked about the
backlash from fans and once again
reaffirmed that the most recent
negotiations between the two companies
had a negative ending with both sides
being unable to compromise on how the
character and expenditures would be
divided going forward he stated that the
company had been trying to work with
Disney and acknowledged that Kevin Feige
was now stretched incredibly thin with
all of the new announcements in phase
four and that this wouldn't be
beneficial to the company that wished to
give spider-man and the spider-verse
their full attention when discussing
this Vince Akira said we had a great run
with Feige on spider-man movies we tried
to see if there's a way to work it out
the Marvel people are terrific people we
have a great respect for them but on the
other hand we have some pretty terrific
people of our own Kevin didn't do all
the work he went on to say that now the
character is fully back in their hands
they plan to launch their own universe
with the vast amount of spider-man
characters they have earlier this week
in an interview with GQ Tom Holland said
that spider-man is in safe hands with
Sony and also say that he would love to
feature on screen with Miles Morales at
some point but whether this is live
action or in the anime
remains to be seen Vince acara also went
on to say spider-man was fine before the
event movies did better with the event
movies and now that we have our own
universe he will play off the characters
as well I think we're pretty capable of
doing what we have to do here this kind
of seems like a bit of a slap in the
face to Disney and whilst he did say
there's no ill will between the two
companies I think this kind of
undervalues a lot of what Disney did and
it's not just a copy and paste formula
as many companies have tried to
replicate the success of the MCU and
every single one of them has failed
honestly like no prize of the person who
can name the one shared universe that's
worked in the comments below and even DC
have struggled to do it and they're
pretty much built quite similar to
Marvel now going forward Jon Favreau
followed up on his earlier comment by
saying I've been talking to everybody
about it I'm cautiously optimistic I
think it's a long way away and I think
the collaboration has been really strong
up to this point so I'm hopeful that
there's a way for us to all play
together going forward
Vince acara - hinted at this saying it's
a long life suggesting that should
projects not pan out with the webhead
that the studio has the option to go
back to Disney and try and find common
ground in which they can both use the
wall-crawler Vince Akira also shut down
rumours that Disney could eventually by
Sony similar to how they did with Fox by
saying that the studio was not for sale
and that's pretty much the end of his
statement going forward this is a pretty
bad blow to those who had hope myself
included that spider-man would remain in
the MCU and whilst personally I don't
really see how the character can just be
up and cough from the franchise as there
are still things that have happened in
it that have molded him to the way that
he is it appears that from now on the
films will not be connected until both
companies are willing to step back into
the boardroom and tried to come to an
agreement it's a real shame that Tom
Holland is pretty much been
Schrodinger's spider the last couple of
weeks with there being a non-stop
barrage of rumors and reports staying
that he's in or out of the MCU
the most recent report stated that Sony
wish to bring Benham to the MCU but it
looks like this may have been
unacceptable for Disney who as mentioned
earlier has stretched incredibly
for the foreseeable future I do believe
that the companies did try to
renegotiate as it's taken a long time to
release an official statement but it
looks like even then that they were
unable to find something that they could
really agree on which is massively
disappointing the one who gets hurt the
most out of this is of course the fans
but I can also see Sony suffering in the
long run with their films probably not
getting the full attention that they
deserve because many people are
threatening to boycott the movies I
think that the MCU will continue to do
fine but spider-man who I would say is
pretty much in everyone's top three
Marvel characters will have a future
that's difficult to predict
obviously I'd love to your thoughts on
the situation now and what you think
will happen with the webhead going
forward comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the ending of it
chapter 2 which would be linked after
this I'll go over everything you need to
know about the film's so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more if you want to come talk to me
about movies TV shows games and comic
books then you can follow me on Twitter
definition YT it's the best way to get
in touch with me and is the perfect
place to suggest new videos and content
so hopefully I see you over there after
this also just wanna let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of John
wick 3 on blu-ray and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is to
like this video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the Sony Disney situation in
the comment section below the winner
will be chosen at random on September
the 10th and the blue arrow be shipped
out from then to a bigoted surprise it's
the best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are super into superheroes so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care
peace
you